a Serling of the calendar means that
Netflix is clearing its library of old
contents and bringing in a truck load of
fresh editions the streamer has
announced an impressive slate of movies
and television shows that will be new to
Netflix throughout April 20 20 amino
Serle dump of popular previously
released action titles are several
franchise entries including all four
installments of the classic action hit
live for weapon which shows up April 1st
once you've got your fix of Mel Gibson
and Danny Glover Spitfire chemistry
you'll want to try your hand at several
other action entries that are classics
in their own right among them are the
nineties video game adaptation Mortal
Kombat's on the first and for quentin
tarantino buffs his bloody academy
award-winning 2013 feature django
unchained which arrives on the 25th
you'll also be able to stream angel as
fallen the third entry in the soso
fallen franchise this installment
follows agent Mike banning played by
Gerard Butler after he's framed for an
assassination attempt on the u.s.
president if you've seen either of the
other two fallen movies you pretty much
know what to expect
look for this on April 4th despite
having several oldies but goodies
populate in this month's lists of action
and adventure releases Netflix is
clearly banking on one new film to be as
number one streaming hits of spring 2020
faster Joe and Anthony Russo produced
Chris Hemsworth lead film extraction
which follows a fearless black market
mercenaries rescue of an imprisoned
crime lords son look for that to drop on
April 24th the current quarantine may
find you more aligned than normal on
your gadgets something that's sure to
have you questioning your ongoing
relationship with your home's digital
intelligence why did the chicken cross
the road I don't know that one why
because humans are a fragile species who
have no idea what's coming next
if the pandemic has you pondering how
you and your tech are going to get along
trapped inside your home together for
the next few months consider watching
these films from some of science
fiction's greatest minds if you haven't
sat down for a neo binge lately
you can reenter the simulation with all
three parts of their Chows keys
game-changing Matrix trilogy or watch
Tom Cruise as he attempts to survive a
very flawed futuristic crime technology
in the philip k dick inspired minority
reports look for those on the first of
the month and despite its lukewarm
critical reception battle Los Angeles
to terrestrial invaders might be just
the thing you're looking for look for
that one on the 27th Netflix has a solid
list of drama titles dropping this month
for those looking to escape the now for
the good old days Netflix has a handful
of April editions right up your alley on
April 16th consider distracting yourself
with the likes of Hollywood a-listers
Josh Brolin George Clooney and Scarlett
Johansson in Hail Caesar a 2016 comedic
mystery drama that sent us on fixer
Eddie Mannix a scramble to save kidnap
dr. Baird Whitlock and his sauce and
sandals epic from certain death sure
good good stuff there's also the music
infused Cadillac records about the
turbulent lives of 1940's musicians or
the high-stakes drama
Molly's game about an aspiring Olympian
who built an underground poker empire
Netflix also has a few darker April
offerings including Robert De Niro's
holy unsettling Turner's Travis Bickle
and the iconic film taxi driver or Jesse
Eisenberg's performance as the only
sometimes unsettling Mark Zuckerberg in
the Facebook origin story the social
network all of those drop on the first
though March 19 2020 mark this year
spring solstice it never really feels
like the new season until April 1st that
makes it the perfect time to opt for a
movie that brightens not dampens your
day these comedy titles coming to
Netflix in April 2020 will make the job
of cheering yourself up by getting in a
good laugh a lot easier ed Helms is
helping lead the comedic charge this
month first with a starring role as the
uptight dentist Jew in the hangover
arriving April 1st and then with his
turn and an all-new Netflix original
starring opposite taraji P Henson and
coffee and Kareem Helms plays police
officer James Coffey his relationship
with Vanessa Manning is being sabotaged
by a 12 year old son Kareem things sake
itself when the boy in Helms must team
up to save her look for that's on the
second in addition to a slew of comedy
specials there's a Ryan Reynolds
addition to the Netflix library that may
or may not win you over though it's
certainly delivers on the same
one-of-a-kind comedic charm that made
the actor a perfect fit for Deadpool
[Music]
just friends as a Christmas comedy about
a high school nerd played by Reynolds
who tries to escape the friend zone of
his longtime crush and best friend and
you can stream it on the 1st of the
month for those looking for funnies in a
different comedic medium stream Krista
Leah's newest stand-up comedy special no
pain on April 14th spring might signal
brighter days ahead but that doesn't
mean you still can't enjoy a darker
flick on Netflix the streamer is
offering a decent amount of sinister
fare in April 2020 from deadly siblings
roommates and neighbors to clowns and
demons Netflix is shrila and horror
offerings for April are frightfully
fantastic start the month with classics
that go out of this world for there
chills like killer clowns from outer
space or tackle your fears of being
replaced with the roommates or 27 scenes
a killing of a sacred deer on April 5th
which follows a cardiovascular surgeon
and his wife after that picture-perfect
suburban life is disrupted by a
fatherless teen who inserts himself into
their lives and the month with a brand
new Netflix original dangerous lies a
star-studded mystery thriller starring
Riverdale's Camila Mendes look for this
on the 30th Disney and Pixar have
dominated the animation field for years
while anime is lively remained an
offshore imports but with a wide range
of highly popular releases like Voltron
legendary defender Shira B stars
Castlevania and devil man cry-baby
Netflix is drawing a future where it's a
true competitor in the genres April 2020
library editions continue now fixes
trend of offering subscribers of a
variety of new and classic anime and
animation the month's most interesting
include the original series at midnight
gospel which follows a so-called space
caster looking for the meaning of life
across the galaxy that's touching down
on a 20th there's also the arrival of
the film that birthed the minions mania
Despicable Me on the 16th as well as two
chapters in the classic bleach anime
franchise bleach the assault and bleach
the bounce
both of those land on the 21st Pokemon
fans can also check out the third season
of Pokemon the series Sun and Moon
subtitled ultra legends on the first of
the month April showers might see you
confined to your house even if common
sense doesn't and that means you'll need
much more than a cinematic
good thing Netflix has a bunch of binge
worthy television series hitting the
stream a service in April 2020 wicked
multi fans who haven't caught one of
showrunner Dan Harmon's earliest Gems
community can loaded the show when all
six seasons trouble at the start of the
month a series follows a group of
heartwarming but oddball community
college students who tried to survive
that non-traditional post-secondary
education and each other on the more
dramatic side expect to see new seasons
on the Ricky Gervais screech centric
drama after life appearing on the 24th
you'll also be able to catch two new
small screen originals first up on the
15th is ounce of banks a young adult
treasure infused mystery about a teens
who search for one's missing father
leads to a treasure map and the long
buried secrets the second never have I
ever arrives on the 27th and as a
coming-of-age drama about a modern first
generation Indian American teen the
series comes from the mind and life of
the office alum Mindy Kaling while
you're busy social distancing you'll
really have no excuse not to get your
money's worth with that Netflix
subscription there's no worse feeling
than opening up the app on your
streaming device of choice to discover
that classic flick you are finally going
to watch has departed from the roles
without ceremony if any of these
features are on your Netflix bucket
lists it's time to get after them with a
renewed sense of urgency on April 29th
Nicolas Cage's found the adventure movie
national treasure is taking a bow the
2004 feature film from Walt Disney
Pictures was produced by Jerry
Bruckheimer and stars Kate alongside an
all-star cast consisting of Harvey
Keitel Sean Bean Justin Bartha Chris
Plummer and Diane Kruger cage plays
historian and cryptologist Benjamin
Franklin gates a man on a quest who
uncovered the lost treasure of the
American Freemasons it's basically The
Da Vinci Code for the whole family which
makes it the perfect bit of escapism to
help your clan get through these
troubled times then comes a real culling
on April 30th at month's end Netflix are
saying goodbye to more than 30 classic
movies including the talented mr. Ripley
True Grit
and Blade Runner the final curse rating
or nuts you can shed a few tears over
those
old moment would be lost in time still
putting off that police academy marathon
you've been planning since before the
holidays better get used to it because
the entire film series is on its way out
at Netflix didn't get your Philip
Scorsese's mobster shtick from the
Irishman well hurry up and stream
Goodfellas because the 1990 crime story
is playing on borrowed time
both scream sequels are scheduled to
follow suit as are other horror classics
Rosemary's Baby Friday the 13th and the
90s which romp the craft if you haven't
seen for Rosa bulk hamming it up as a
teenage Wiccan gone to the dark side and
you haven't lived the beginning of
spring is usually a time when most of us
turn off the TV step out of our soft
pants and squeeze back into some jeans
to venture outside from our winter
hibernation
unfortunately this spring is going to be
a little different but maybe you're more
of a binge watch sure than a cinephile
so if cannonballing five seasons of
premium television is your preferred
coping mechanism then Netflix has some
good news for you in the upcoming weeks
comparatively few of the streamers
lauded television series are headed for
the exit in April early in the month
Netflix is saying sayonara to American
Odyssey season 1 a 2015 thriller series
that originally aired on NBC was adapted
from a UK series entitled simply Odyssey
the first and only season stars Anna
Friel and Peter Facinelli as US military
personnel employed in an international
crisis when a military team on a mission
to Mali discovers that an American
company has been secretly funding a
violent group of Islamic extremists if
you enjoy shows like homeland and Jack
Ryan American Odyssey just may be your
cup of tea then mid month or five
seasons of Lost Girl are getting well
lost the Canadian series began airing on
Sci Fi in the u.s. beginning in 2020
after originally debuting on showcase in
2010 it stars Anna selcas Bo a bisexual
succubus in the big city
perfect for fans of Supernatural or the
Vampire Diaries and with five seasons of
demonic content two panes before April
16th
you'd better get cracking a sub check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos buy your
favorite movies and shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't
a single one
[Music]